yo Israel's president let out the
caretaker Prime Minister to announce the
result he'd been trying to avoid Reuven
Rivlin wanted Benjamin Netanyahu to form
a national unity government with his
main rival Benny Gant's those talks
failed and instead he chose the man with
a bigger potential coalition bloc to
have the first chance at forming a
government decision on who should be
handed the task of forming the
government depends on who has more
chance to succeed currently 55 supported
Knesset member Netanyahu and 54
supported Knesset member Benny Gantz
however 10 of them said they wouldn't
sit with him in a government before the
announcement a second meeting between
Netanyahu and Ganz at the president's
home served merely to confirm what was
already clear the talks between their
parties had gone nowhere
neither man reportedly willing to go
second in a rotational prime minister
agreement Netanyahu said he would
continue to push for such a deal within
days the pressure is on his first
pre-indictment hearings on corruption
charges are due next week I said out of
the utmost with the mandate you gave me
if I don't succeed I'll return the
mandate to you and with the help of God
and Israel citizens and yourself mr.
president we establish a broad national
unity government down the line after the
announcement Gantz reiterated that he
would not serve under a prime minister
facing indictment who insisted on
bringing with him a large block of
right-wing parties the longer the
process goes on the closer he gets to
being charged the more pressure mounts
on Netanyahu to stand aside but if Benny
ganses strategy is simply to wait until
conditions favour him well the president
reminded him that he had another option
he could merely toss the ball to the
Knesset and ask it to find an
alternative candidate who could muster
61 recommendations the president has
made his initial choice but it's no
breakthrough Israel's political
stalemate goes on Harry Fawcett al
Jazeera West Jerusalem